and you know who will be at the aces
rally cheering on the Champs the Raiders
oh I love it Rocky stopped by their
studio just ahead as they are you know
we are getting ready for their
celebrations take a look
raiderettes the studio is officially
open to the public but before we get to
those details we gotta talk about the
obvious we have a championship team in
town our Aces how does that feel for you
guys as a you know Sister team in the
city we could not be more proud we are
so excited so proud of these women and
all the hard work that they put in all
season and we just can't wait to
celebrate with them today what's the
plan today you guys are you just going
out there and dancing around or is there
like a line you guys are following we
will be a part of the parade and then we
have our high rollers dance team
performing as well so it's fun for
everybody come on out I love it now
let's get to the details this is a huge
announcement you guys just opened your
exclusive raiderette Studio to the
community where people can come in and
have classes All Families invited as
well so let's break it down Maria what
can people enjoy here at the studio okay
so we're really excited to share that
we've opened up to the public everyone
across Las Vegas and Henderson can feel
free to join us for Fitness classes and
dance class so for their for all
children and then also we have classes
in the daytime for adults so we have
Jazz we have hip hop we have Palm we our
most popular classes right now are
Raider at cheer and palm classes so
we're gonna have some future raid rats
coming through here too we sure are and
I couldn't be more excited about that is
there a website or somewhere where they
can actually sign up for the classes yes
it's Raider at the studio.com all right
Raider atthestudio.com you guys set your
classes up for the entire family and
come get classes with the raiderettes
we'll be back later on in the show